here we go
I should hear you to come out your nose
loud
[Music]
stop your eyes closed put your hands
pulls up on your lap
and just feel
feel if you feel any tingling in your
body
feel if you feel maybe a sense of peace
maybe a hint of happiness every now and
then for some of you just for no good
reason except you wanted
we're gonna do three sets of thirty
again three sets of ten here we go hands
come up as we breathe in
[Music]
palms up eyes closed once again just
feel whatever you feel
[Music]
relaxation tingling perhaps a sense of
peace
some of you that might be a little
joy happen as the Gravesend
just kiss it's enjoyable why not
one more set of thirty three sets of ten
here we go
[Music]
breathing deep enjoying it
they might just take your hands and put
them on your heart for a moment
physically feel your heart and breathe
deep in your heart feel the power of
your heart
the strength of your heart
the beauty of your heart
what are you proud your heart has guided
you to feel or to give or to do or to
share what you enjoy
[Music]
as long as that heart is beating you
live and something something in the
universe God the universe some energy
some infant intelligence whatever you
call it who loved you enough to give you
this heart you didn't have to earn it it
knew you were enough before you were
born
so give thanks for this beautiful heart
that beats a hundred thousand times a
day without you even having to think
about it it beats even when you sleep
there as long as it beats you live what
a gift
now for three minutes a minute each
start with one memory one moment in your
life you could feel incredibly grateful
for if you want to do what's a moment
could've been with your kids through
your husband or wife or friends or by
yourself for prayer or sporting moon any
moment all that you could feel so
grateful for and then step back in that
moment as if you were there now
looking through your own demise seeing
when you saw them as if it was happening
now breathing
hearing feeling that feeling of
gratitude as if you were there right now
take a moment and fill up with that
memory like you're there
enjoy
savoring
fill up with that gratitude moment you
love the moment that is precious
[Music]
think of a second moment now he could
feel deeply grateful for it could be
anything for her childhood as an adult
could have been ten years ago could have
been yesterday here today
any moment you can feel deeply grateful
for
[Music]
stepped into that moment right now like
you're there once again seeing hearing
feeling
while you're feeling that
[Music]
fill up with that gratitude
savor
[Music]
give thanks
feels so grateful
[Music]
think of a third moment now
you're deeply grateful for if you want
[Music]
see and feel it here and experience him
he might even feel it smile inside that
starts to show up slightly on your face
if you wanted to
[Music]
fill up with the beauty of that moment
the love or the sacredness or the gift
of that magic moment
feels at that moment was a blessing and
your lash wasn't it
and then just for fun think of a
coincidence that you're grateful for you
know we all love coincidences because we
didn't make it happen it was life
happening for us not to us you're
heading to a restaurant or to a meeting
and you met the love of your life we
weren't planning on our business partner
or even exposed to an idea that changed
your life and you didn't do it life God
the universe brought it to you it's
really beautiful when we can start the
sea the life is always happening for us
not to us
even the problems are gifts if we learn
from them they lead to greater growth
aliveness love certainty strength
what's a coincidence you're grateful for
that happened because it led to
something
your treasure you value you appreciate
your grateful
fill up with that gratitude was it a
coincidence
Oh were you guys
[Music]
we're gonna go to step two now imagine
you didn't wash your hands off your
heart if you haven't already imagine an
energy it can be the gold lights a white
light that ice blue light coming from
the sky from space and heavens down
through the top of your head
the crown of your head and as it goes
through that white or gold or blue light
penetrates your skull your neck your
shoulders your arms your chest your
lower back your stomach your legs calves
through the feet into the ground
circling the core of the earth imagine
it and then imagine it's circling back
up to the top and out the top of your
head back down on it as it does feel the
energy come in and imagine that your
life your mind your emotion your body
are being healed and strengthened all
the way into the earth back up your legs
through the chest through the top you
had it out with the sky
[Music]
keep bringing it down a new Gale of an
energy linked yourself as you do this
heal my body heal my mind
heal my spirit strengthen me strengthen
the best parts of me my courage my faith
my determination I love my passion my
compassion my caring and then do it
again this feeling each time it's almost
like a cleansing and strengthening up
your whole nervous system like every
cell every nerve in your body feels
alive
he'll strengthened like the best parts
of you are getting stronger you love
your joy your playfulness your laughter
your faith your determination your
persistence your love so you feel really
the energy or trust affair it's like a
prayer or a blessing
now take that energy in your heart and
send the people closest to you imagine
they don't even have to know it that
you're sending energy into them that
heals their mind their heart their
emotions their body
that it strengthens the best in them
their joy their love their happiness
their determination to encourage their
faith their joy it's hard for us to be
blessed that we don't want the same
blessings for others
just fill up with that energy that
yields and strengthens you and those you
love emotionally
and finally our third step you're gonna
think of three results three outcomes
three goals that you want to turn into
reality we'll take a minute each one at
a time I want you to imagine that you've
already achieved that goal you've
already made it happen and you're
feeling it there should be a smile
inside you you're celebrating it and how
the beaut if you're achieving that no
way makes your life better but allows
you to touch others that you love care
about reach out to so see it goal or
desire that you really want to make
happen but don't think about making it
happen see it as done feel it celebrate
it like it's the ultimate victory feel
grateful for like you were guided to the
result
really feel the excitement of it the joy
of it awesome you're doing great great
job then think of a second goal or
outcome but really see and feel yourself
achieving it and then celebrating it and
see with that but it brings to your life
for the people you care about and feel
the joy the excitement the fun of it the
pride making it happen as if it's
happened already right now in this
moment
finally think of a third uncover result
you want a goal you want to make real
step in it like you're there see and
feel yourself achieving it and being out
of your mind with excitement and
gratitude and joy you might even just
make yourself smile really you should
think of it or a subtle one inside
whatever you prefer they're really
feeling the appreciation of this the
gratitude the excitement of it the joy
of it
it is done
whew
breather
[Music]
then just say thank you thank you
I love you thank you
[Music]
to get a green filling this gratitude
feeling the joy filling the blessings
your mind body heart and seal the
blessings to those you love and meet and
start to feel the achievement the joy
the excitement and start to build that
energy a little bit inside like the
energy is building up inside you and
it's gonna build to a beedi where you're
gonna expand and make a sound a few
minutes not just yet
feel so grateful so happy so blessed
when you're ready you can open your eyes
[Music]
when you're ready slowly when you're
ready you can rise up and begin to
stretch your body and just feel that
energy inside you building strengthening
giving grateful and then let the energy
rise up stand up and rise up stand your
body in a few moments we're gonna make a
sound the loudest sound you've ever made
that you could enjoy making a sound of
joy of excitement a playfulness of grace
of guidance and of sound you make if you
are thinking the universe our God for
all it's inside you all that you've
lived all that you're going to live all
that's coming get ready to build it up
faith joy excitement energy passion more
excitement more energy more joy than
ever get ready one
[Applause]
[Music]
the Richard cited double the intensity
router and enjoy it
[Music]
bring it into our hearts take the
feelings inside feel it in you as you it
is you your spirit and soul awakened
it's you that awakens you awaken
yourself with gratitude you're waking
yourself with grace waking yourself with
appreciation you're waking yourself by
seeing and commanding and celebrating
what you want not begging for it like
you're weak knowing it's in you as you
this is you we're not made to be small
or less we're made to feel fully 1 2 3
make the sound
[Music]
if you want to know why Tony does this
morning an exercise and understand the
principles behind it check the link
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy that video continue to believe and
I'll see you there
every day of our lives we live in a
world that is incredibly complex and you
have to remember we all have a
two-million-year-old brain